she'll go on to the end we shall never
surrender dumped of the story the
British people are very unique and very
compelling pair that hasn't been told in
modern buildings and so fulfill negative
to resist Chris calls the IMF Tambor the
gold standard he saw a number of our
early movies and he said jeez really be
cool if we could do something in the
Hollywood feature his first experience
using an IMAX camera was on the prestige
and the Dark Knight was the one we
really worked very closely together
really one of the audience to go through
this experience and so we shot the film
on IMAX we shot the film large format we
were doing handheld we lost good app
help you lost 3d IMAX camera I like to
control pro camera I like is a very sort
of crazy real camera that can be in the
middle of the action so we could make
shots from the hospital an airplane if
you off the path in terms of resolution
there is nothing better than IMAX camera
on the IMAX film prints the audience
gains through the higher resolution with
internal analog color get a very very
immersive experience film it's 17 times
more nuanced than a digital picture it
has that organic feeling it's an art
form and Chris really wants to keep that
art form alive imax sounds has been
amazing from our very beginning our
sound
it's an octave lower than anybody else's
our surrounds our full dynamic range
when those 50 fires go by you can
actually feel it we have this beautiful
window into the world one of the
clearest ice you can imagine IMAX is
really the way to see this film trying
to put the audience on that beach and on
the grandest Candice with available to
us which is IMAX film
you know Serena
you